they had us put the suits on and then
just jump around like that was one of
the most bizarre experiences of my life
some actors faced costume struggles
while special return visitors to the
spider-man world got some much
appreciated costume upgrades which actor
had some extra padding who could finally
see properly on set here we go
number one when will someone give them a
flap we've had three different actors
playing spider-man over multiple years
yet somehow every single one of them has
continued to suffer when it comes to
taking bathroom breaks it got so bad for
tom that the actor actually avoided
drinking too much water on set knowing
that he'd need about 45 minutes to get
out of the suit before even being able
to go to the bathroom andrew felt the
spidey struggle really brought them
together though explaining there was a
brotherhood that got created between
toby tom and myself you find it hard to
pee in the suit i find it hard to pee in
the suit hopefully one day it'll be a
bit easier for them to escape the curses
of that suit
number two looks cool doesn't feel cool
that's why when i shoot webs in the suit
i i don't do this the iron spider-man
suit was a major upgrade kitted out with
all the tools a person could need but it
wasn't the easiest to work in
tom sympathized for what after a while
would be a very bruised up peter parker
they may have looked slick in the end
but those gauntlets were a spidey fail
we gotta have that web shooting move
without inhibition
number three the man who began it all
toby sported the og spidey suit but it
was pretty unique compared to the ones
the others wore but one thing it didn't
do so well was hold up maguire's
original was falling apart and totally
unusable since the spidey tech from the
early 2000s wasn't nearly as advanced as
it is now that being said they did build
his suit from scratch honoring the
original design including his silver
webs and different muscle definition
details but it came with some upgrades
it wasn't always a blast to wear but the
zippers were better placed this time
around so it was a bit easier and more
comfortable to whip on and off
number four ah yes the broody one andrew
garfield's dark and broody spider-man
was a different style since garfield had
such a different physique from the other
peter parkers considering how long it's
been since he wore the spidey suit
garfield was intimidated knowing it
would be even more difficult to work in
saying i'm no spring chicken anymore the
actor did work out a lot though so he
was able to strut onto set knowing he
looked as good as he felt even if he was
a bit constricted in that lycra
number five he didn't have real
tentacles but they were just as fierce
alfred molina had the rare delight of
actually kind of enjoying his costume
doc ock was back and looking fierce as
ever only in more practical and
comfortable hardware melina was very
impressed explaining that it was
surprisingly comfortable the nice thing
about the design was that it looked good
but it felt like clothing it didn't feel
like a costume instead of having to be
aware of actual tentacles around him the
back of molina's coat had circles cut
out and filled with blue so cgi could
work its magic after the fact to bring
those arms onto the screen his heavy
looking metal belt was brilliantly
designed by sanja hayes who made it
extra comfortable with lightweight
fabric that was painted to appear heavy
duty this new take on the outfit allowed
the team to respect the original designs
while amping it all up a bit
number six time to ditch the mask willem
dafoe isn't the same green goblin he was
all those years ago and neither was the
suit he wore in no way home his clunky
hard-looking costume was totally
upgraded and made it much easier for the
actor to fight the new suit design was
courtesy of the visual development
department who actually 3d printed a
version of the suit that was then filled
with poured in foam making for a much
easier to put on costume we're talking a
jumpsuit with zipper style this was a
big improvement and the new tech allowed
to foe to not leave the set feeling
totally broken number 7 bye bye vfx body
electro makes an impact on screen
looking totally upgraded and fresh as an
actual person in a suit instead of pure
blue electricity the major difference
for jamie foxx was that he was actually
able to wear a costume and have his real
face appear on screen the costume
brought worker clothing with an
electrifying twist with all those
reactor details incorporated since his
body was on screen he found himself
rigged up in the air sporting his now
elaborate look but it definitely took a
learning curve to get used to
number eight a little padding goes a
long way was it muscle padding well sort
of and i'm not gonna tell you who but
one of us has a fake ass in their suit
and which spidey was it you can figure
out that for yourself tom only knew
because he got a bit distracted by it
one day wow
oh hang on a minute nah that's not real
we may never know who had a little extra
junk in the trunk since all the
spider-man actors have had each other's
back weary to reveal any details that
would out any one of them number nine
once a spider-man always a spider-man
peeling into the suit there is nothing
quite like it it was uncomfortable
getting it on and then and then it's a
goof it brings me back into that
character it was still physically
uncomfortable and the actor was aware of
just how much that material could show
but it was worth it eventually being in
lycra or spandex you know once that goes
away you're like oh wow this is this is
cool this is a responsibility but a but
a blessing number 10. not every suit is
what it appears to be each spidey in
fact had two versions of all their
different suits one with a little kind
of turtleneck cut for when they weren't
wearing the mask and another that was
made to go with the hood with cuts and
seams that met up flawlessly beneath
each mask there was also a skull cap
mask it made breathing tough but
protected those pretty faces from
getting scratched up by the tougher
outer mask each spidey face also
featured frames around the eyes so they
could be snapped right into place and
that's why tom was able to sip through
straws
number eleven is it black and gold or
red and blue technically this suit is
kinda both since it was made to look
like the regular spidey suit but inside
out included in this eye-catching
costume were fine gold wire detailing
that would be the hidden circuitry
inside fortunately the suit wasn't so
uncomfortable as it would have been had
it actually just been the regular suit
inside out we didn't see the same suit
the team was seeing on set though the
vfx department added their own touches
to really make this suit stand out on
screen
number 12 no face or touch recognition
no access the lycra spidey suit is
useful for peter parker's high flying
his texting abilities not so much when
they're in the suits all the spider-man
actors were limited in how much they
could actually use their phones and
let's be honest with a suit that tight
it's not like there were many places
they could safely tuck their phones away
for filming anyhow number 13. it's
hybrid suit time tom was sporting a red
and black suit on set that looks very
much like what we see on screen but the
reality is what we usually see is a
fully digital suit over top of the
actor's body this digital detailing
includes layers on layers of digital
fabric including metallic inlays and
overlays all woven in together and
mimicking the movement fabric would
actually have on his body the task of
replacing the suit in all those frames
was probably most tough on the editing
team who spent hours making the
appropriately dubbed hybrid spider-man
suit a reality
number 14. the people want what they
want was anyone really a fan of the old
green goblin mask willem dafoe had heard
what was up explaining i am aware that
there was some criticism of the mask in
the original one we heard that it was
probably a consideration to change it up
a little bit they ditched the clunky old
style in exchange for a costume that's
gone above and beyond for fans even
including the classic purple hood and
for defoe the whole switch was a great
improvement as well not including the
mask meant he could hear and see
properly so you can bet the actor was a
fan of these changes
number 15 no suit left behind while the
og suits didn't all get used each of
them was on set to be used as a
reference and to recognize just how much
history was actually coming together in
this showstopper of a film the old
spidey suits were either covered in dirt
and holes or literally disintegrating
not so fun to look at or wear but they
still contain something very special all
that spidey sense love him or hate him
these suits are totally worth wearing in
the end considering just how good they
look on screen
whose spidey suit do you think had a
little extra butt padding